juli etwas gedacht und herzlich
willkommen zum video ich hoffe natürlich
geht es gut ich habe letztens ein paar
neue erfahrungen gesammelt die mich dann
auf den weg gebracht haben dieses video
heute zu drehen und zwar hatte ich in
meinem büro noch ziemlich viele sachen
rumfliegen die ich einfach so gar nicht
losgeworden bin dann habe ich dir
gebündelt und im internet versteigert in
verschiedenen packages oder
verschiedenen kategorien und jetzt dann
aufgefallen dass wirklich alles weg ging
zwar nicht immer zusammen guten preis
aber immerhin bin ich losgeworden muss
aber trotzdem sagen dass ich zufrieden
war damit und dadurch bin ich dann auf
den trichter gekommen mich selber mal
mit so optionen zu beschäftigen und
dachte mir ja die startet man am besten
ich habe in den letzten tagen aktiv
ausschau gehalten nach so apple ware
ausstellungs ware vielleicht waren die
leicht effekt ist macbooks ipad smart
switches oder apple watcher ich konnte
jetzt einige sachen unter anderem auf
wieder steigern airports ihr ipads wir
haben ein macbook was ich mehr richtig
funktioniert glaube ich der apple watch
zu wirklich sehr sehr humanen preisen es
ist auf jeden fall als angekommen wir
werden uns das jetzt mal in ruhe
anschauen und dann werden wir auch
versuchen das ganze in schuss zu bringen
und ich glaube ich sehe hier wirklich
potenzial das man damit geld verdienen
kann als das so plump sagen kann was ich
aber noch ganz gut sagen wollte und zwar
hier kam es in letzter zeit nicht so oft
ein video das wird auch wieder besser
ich habe mir gerade neben youtube echt
viele andere projekte und checkt gern
mal anderen kanal aus da kommen jeden
tag in berlin ab laut ansonsten könnt
ihr euch die nächste woche auch wieder
auf andere videos freuen sollte ich
einmal gesagt haben und jetzt bis gleich
leute was geht da sind wir bei mir zu
hause tatsächlich guck mal hier alles
apple da also das ist wirklich gute
ausbeute die ich hier gemacht habe und
da schauen wir uns jetzt mal genauer an
womit staatlich also eines von den
sachen ist hier drin was anders sein
weil ja das ist ja ein riesenpaket
eigentlich können das nur airports oder
apple watch sein wir haben wir die ipads
drin und hierherkommt starten einfach
mal hier mit ich war auch heute mal so
schlau und hab mir ein messer
mitgenommen aus dem büro hat zwar wie
schon gesagt zum großen teil wurden
diese waren als ausstellungs waren
beziehungsweise halt einfach defekte
waren verkauft ich sehe schon hier haben
wir das macbook pro da bin ich wirklich
mal gespannt drauf weil ich muss sagen
ich glaube angeboten wurde das für 180
euro ich hab es allerdings für 140 dann
bekommen und sogar mit karton das wusste
ich gar nicht schaut mal hier neues
macbook ich hoffe mal das funktioniert
und ist in einem halbwegs guten zustand
weil irgendwas sowohl damit seien aber
dann gibt es ja mich um das mal checken
ansonsten muss ich mir dann natürlich
auch wieder unterstützung vom profi
holen aber 140 euro hierfür kann man
eigentlich nicht meckern sagt rach
designed by apple in california ich
glaube das müsste aus dem jahr 2014
seien stand dabei also schon alter schon
acht jahre alt und es ist trotzdem noch
na ja gut ich bin euch jemand ein paar
aufnahmen einen wir haben hier ein paar
beulen drauf dann empfiehlt hier einer
von diesen knüppeln und ein paar spuren
sind schon dran dann haben wir hier noch
dabei das ladekabel das warst du noch
schon ich würde sagen wir checken ob es
angeht das klingt schon mal gut der
bildschirm ist naja ich sehe ja auch
schon eine stelle wo man scheint so als
wäre man in schwerer gegenstand gegen
gekommen oder so also ich weiß nicht wie
man es nennt aber das leuchtet hier also
ein bisschen blau also sieht nicht
normal aus sonst aber alles okay und es
geht auch an schaut mal hier also ich
hab mal geguckt die dinger werden nach
wie vor also genau dieses gerät noch für
300 euro verkauft deswegen eigentlich
alles richtig gemacht hallo der
zwischenzeit können wir gerne schon mal
mit einer anderen sache weiter macht
auch ohne titel installieren noch
ungefähr 13 minuten macht sinn das wird
wahrscheinlich zurückgesetzt oder sticks
konnte auf ihrem computer nicht ins
scheiße
das klingt eigentlich schon mal nicht so
gut ja ja ja ich habe es mir schon
gedacht das ist ein bisschen einmal
probiert es noch wenn es dann nicht geht
muss ich mich damit mal ausführlich
beschäftigen aber das machen wir nicht
jetzt also ich habe jetzt noch einmal
probiert ist immer noch die gleiche
fehlermeldung das ist echt schade aber
das wäre schon hinbekommen also es kann
ja nicht sein dass man so alte macbooks
einfach nicht nur installieren kann und
jetzt würde ich fragen machen wir hier
mit weiter das ist ich habe keine ahnung
wieso hier eine 15 drauf geschrieben
wurde aber vielleicht erfahren wir das
ja nicht dass das jetzt eines von den
paketen ist was mir meine zuschauer
schicken konnten für meinen anderen
kanal habe ich nämlich ganz viele
zuschauer unboxing machte übrigens alle
sehr wundervoll geworden sind und ihr
euch die unbedingt einziehen sollte hh
schaut mal hier kann man es sehen was
steht da apple watch wir haben hier eine
apple watch die hab ich geschossen für
50 euro oder 55 euro das ist eine series
4 liegen ja sonst lief es bei auf jeden
fall circa 200 deswegen habe ich da auch
eine chance gewittert und wir schauen
uns jetzt mal genau ich glaube die war
destroyed aber solange sie angeht ist
das kein grund zu panik guck mal also
wirklich an sich alles super apple sache
sind einfach immer neues auszupacken
guck mal alles noch die guten zustand
außerdem watch die hat glaube ich wird
immer vielleicht habe ich ja auch
einfach glück ja ihr könnt hier sehen
das display ist beschädigt aber das ist
kein problem weil so ein apple watch
display ist nicht so teuer wie ein
iphone display ich weiß halt nur nicht
ob ich den ausgetauscht bekommen das
habe ich nämlich noch nie gemacht geht
an das ist schonmal wunderbare ganz
ehrlich also unding für 55 euro oder was
ich da bezahlt hat da kann man doch
nicht mehr kann oder das ist doch
absolut in ordnung series vier so leute
hier apple bot ich glaube die
funktioniert einwandfrei das einzige
problem ist halt das display und das
werde ich auf jeden fall brauche ich
erstmal für ein maximal 40 euro
reparieren und dann habe ich ca 90 euro
bezahlt und die werte zwischen 150 und
200 23 euro verkauft also eigentlich ein
guter deal lohneis während das
software-update lädt ich muss irgendwie
neues update das ist auch egal machen
wir weiter mit dem nächsten paket und
ich glaube in diesem paket da freue ich
mich am meisten drauf wir sind vier
ipads drin vier stück alles ausstellungs
ware aus irgendeinem geschäft hier ipad
2 haben auf jeden fall auch im werte
eines solchen dingen wird auch noch gut
200 euro bezahlt und ich habe viel stück
ersteigert für 200 euro oder 203 euro
oder so ich habe es nicht mehr genau im
kopf wunderschön nummer eins ipad apple
ipad 2 wifi 16gb dann haben wir das
zweite das dritte und das vierte
alter
apple-stores aufmachen
angespannt hey wunderschön immer
tadellos hier ist kein einziger katzer
raum ganz kleiner die rückseite sieht
ein bisschen schlecht aus als das
display aber vorsichtig ich muss
fairerweise sagen ich lauere also ich
habe gehofft ich habe wirklich gehofft
dass ich das nur auf ein tablett bezieht
oder ein ipad aber ich denke mal alle
von denen haben keinen akku ich weiß
nicht warum ich hab es leider erst zu
spät gesehen mein gebot war schon
abgelegt und ich dachte wieviel 200 euro
kannst du nichts falsch machen die haben
leider glaube ich okay das lag doch das
hier ist ein bisschen schwerer das ist
schon mal ein gutes zeichen in dem safe
kein akku drin aber es ist auch nicht so
schlimm kommen bitte gern bitte gern
billige anbiete und her auf jeden fall
mega entspannt wenn das endlich angehen
würde ich ja sehr gut dann stecken wir
jetzt mal die anderen ab hier ist keine
akute drin aber die sind so alt wie kann
man einfach aufmachen das kein problem
jack mal gerade was für ein akku kostet
hoffe nicht zu viel damit habe ich
nämlich einmal nicht geschäft ich habe
einfach das gebot abgegeben fakt ist ja
okay geht klar zwischen 20 und 30 euro
kriegt man auf jeden fall ein akku das
ist verkraftbar weil überlegt war ich
verkauft jedes 450 hatte 400 euro gewinn
gemacht er ist auch kein akku drin naja
aber misst und das displays auch
geschrottet schaut mal na ja ein steht
immerhin hätte besser laufen können ich
habe halt gehofft dass wirklich nur eins
ohne akku ist all das konnte man aus der
beschreibung nicht klar entnehmen und
die anderen alle funktionieren aber dem
war nicht so pech gehabt neben geht
weiter ihr könnt ja sehr gerne
kommentieren leute ist trotzdem guter
dinge gewesen oder könnt ihr mir
eigentlich umsatz überlegen da immer
eingeblendet wird wenn es ein cooler
deal war an den ihr euch dann gewöhnen
können bei ich habe ja öfter mal so
pakete die ich aus pappe aus habe ich
selber halt genau und hier haben wir
airports sind auch nicht schlecht die
habe ich für 40 euro auf plus 4 euro 90
versand also knapp 45 euro die sind auch
natürlich gebraucht trotzdem fand ich
das auf jeden fall in ordnung also
meisterpreis war noch mit abstand die
günstigste dies gab und immer davon aus
dass man da auch aufgeladen ja die sind
halt leider ein bisschen dreckig das ist
eigentlich immer das eklig sinne wenn so
etwas wirklich dreckig sind also so
richtig dreckig voll mit ohrenschmalz
und da ist immer noch ein bisschen rum
da hättest du das nicht vorher mal für
mich selber machen kann das recht
korrekt willst dich erstmal koppeln das
wäre natürlich jetzt auch ein witz wenn
das einfach fake sind nur weil ich habe
ja letztens noch fix außerdem auf einem
anderen kanal gehabt und man schaut mal
hier so das sind fakes die kosten in
spanien china und das sieht halt eins zu
eins leicht aus dann kannst du am sound
erkennen und da höre ich jetzt neben
rein so koppeln die sind auf jeden fall
original das ist schon mal gut wie werde
ich sauber machen und ich glaube auch
das war ein guter deal nice tibro das
ist feuerschein ich hab was gutes zu dir
viel also guter deal gutes gefühl ich
kann man dann immer so hier so ein wenn
also das war auf jeden fall gut dir gut
fehlt die dinger hier auch eigentlich
alles ich bin zufrieden ich bin wirklich
mal gespannt was wir hier rausholen
können leute was geht ich möchte mich
noch mal kurz bildung kleiner nachtrag
und zwar hab ich leider dann doch noch
herausgefunden display für ipads lohn zu
überhaupt nicht ist viel zu teuer
deswegen kann man das display schon mal
außen vor lassen einiges gilt leider für
die apple watch ich habe also mit 50
euro berechnet vielleicht aber das
display auch da kostet gern mal 130 watt
pc oder das ist einfach nur deswegen ja
hätte ich auch mal vorher genauer
schicken sollen ich habe mich da
irgendwie auf meine erfahrung verlassen
die in dem die themengebiete leider noch
nicht so ausgeprägt war aber kopf in den
sand stecke ich denke dass wir trotzdem
gut am ende und ja das wollte ich noch
gesagt haben nächste woche kommt wie
gesagt mal wieder ein anderes video und
ich bedanke mich fürs zuschauen sagt auf
jeden fall meinen anderen kanal beutel
haut rein